in the 90s when i started having more
sort of broader success
it was so unexpected
and it just it played to all of my
and maybe this is very very obvious but
it played all of my insecurities it
played to my
my feel my lack of self-worth
my
feelings of inadequacy the demons are
within us and so is the divinity within
us the god and the devil are both you
know within within the human being all
of those aspects but we can choose to
express
on whatever
spectrum of the polarity we want to
express from the most extreme
enlightened divine side or from the
darkest power driven ego driven denial
of our divinity denial of sameness
of all people and all beings we can
express that way too and you can go
through history and see the people
who've expressed
at the extremes and then most of us fall
somewhere in the middle the biggest
issue i see today hands down across
everything the reason people i believe
suffer so much the reason there's so
much comparison feeling not enough
feeling not good enough all of these um
like
these forms of suffering come from one
root cause which is that we over
identify with the ego what we must do is
to aggressively love the ego and when
i'm here telling you that the ego is
doing something super bad the natural
reflection for a human is to be like all
right then we gotta push the ego away
well that's how it wins right there the
ego is incredibly beneficial but unless
we really spend time to understand it
and figure out how to meet its needs and
by doing so
come in as a kind of like you know i'm
caretaking the ego as a tool of my own
rather than it's the thing that runs me
we're not going to be able to make this
transition happen to my great shame i
sort of succumbed to the narcissism and
the self-involvement that comes along
with that
you know where you where for a while i'm
ashamed to say i expected people to sort
of know who i was and to treat me
differently
and that
it's just not a it's not a healthy way
to live i mean we look at our culture
and there's so many public figures who
are sort of destroyed by being public
figures
you know it's it's very i mean it's not
just
confusing it's sometimes it brings out
the worst parts of our personalities so
i
am glad that i
personally have sort of gone past that
we're like you know like
i guess i'm still a public figure but
it's not necessarily how i think of
myself on a day-to-day basis yeah well i
think people regulate against the things
that they're scared of themselves and
when the ego is in control right the ego
is firmly in control it's scared of the
and scared of losing its power seat
running the human organs right it it's
almost like an entity that itself wants
to survive by the belief of the organism
that it exists in
like the ego wants to be real like i
want to be a real boy surface confidence
is in the ego so for me it used to be
like look at my straight a's it was all
like my worth was in my grades always my
perfectionism but the problem is out
here is this swirl of dynamic change all
the time so if we pin our confidence to
anything out here it's always going to
go up and down so the true source of
confidence yoga teaches us and when you
peel away the layers and the layers and
you keep going deeper and deeper is one
thing danica it's very simple confidence
in the very purest sense comes from i am
i'm here i'm alive i'm breathing i'm a
drop of consciousness i'm spirit
individualized whatever word you want to
use you know the universe
whatever but i am here i am present i am
alive and that is where the real
confidence comes from
so a lot of us engage in this arduous
pushing externally the ego is like
wanting to say oh you need to do more
you need to get more even the way we
approach love we think we need to get
love from other people we need to get
this and this and that's the ego
playing out lack
and the opposite is when we realize that
we are in charge of our we can what we
can work with is our inner state
and it's this frequency inside of us
abundance is really showing with the
fullness of this moment so we're we're
here and we're present we're breathing
and we're not lacking anything we're not
comparing ourselves we're not an ego
identification we are in connection with
this essence inside of us and then that
repeated frequency over time starts to
attract and create people are drawn to
you people say oh what are you what is
this what are you working on they want
to you know opportunities come and more
relationships things get deeper and i
got deeper and deeper into this after my
you know rock bottom place about four
years ago and now i'm like oh my gosh it
doesn't have to be as arduous and
pushing and living from the ego as we've
been led to believe there's this whole
other way of living how do we love the
ego how do we understand the ego you
understand the value of having a self
you understand the value of the aspects
itself and by virtue of understanding
the value you know what place to put it
in i think the recognition of the ego is
the first step you can look at buddhist
monks for example you've got people who
have taken themselves out of society put
themselves in a monastery and they're
practicing this for 80 years straight
it's even more difficult when you're in
the world and you've got so many
triggers for the ego but the recognition
of the ego which is this perception
separate self is the first step i think
people just regulate against the stuff
that they're afraid of okay and so
people who have strong egos were afraid
of these things that were ego dissolving
and so you know we outlawed those but
the consequences of that are that we
don't have the tools to really resolve
the traumas and really unwind some of
these patterns and i think that's the
the revolution that's coming with this
next wave of psychedelic medicine and
somehow i felt that you know if people
were nice to me you know if people
wanted to date me if people invited me
to their parties it sort of gave me this
external
sort of validation
and as is often the case i became way
too attached to it
you know because
you know i had grown up you know
my mom and i were on food stamps and
welfare i was you know a little insecure
kid growing up and then suddenly when
you're on the receiving end of the
tension
you know especially glamorous attention
it can be really
corrupting you know it's because it's so
it's so attractive so what is the ego
the ego is this part of us that's
sensing with the five senses so it's
what we see with our physical eyes
including looking in the mirror what we
look like what other people are doing on
social media it's always looking out
touching hearing what's out here we are
having an embodied experience we are
here in a physical body so of course we
are going to have an ego to an extent we
need to be in the world but the issue is
when we put our full identity and our
self-worth
in this
so anytime you you're saying to yourself
hmm
i don't feel good enough you see
something that triggers you like someone
walks by and you're like oh i should be
i should be 10 pounds lighter or
whatever or something happens or you
know whatever you see a social media
post and you think whatever it is
it's important that first of all in that
moment you pause and that feeling comes
up you start to recognize it and you say
oh
i'm identifying with my ego in this
moment fear is being an ego because if
i'm an ego i'm scared that oh my god i'm
getting older my body's gonna break down
all this stuff's gonna happen to me and
you know someone's gonna outdo my stuff
my project at work i'm not gonna get the
promotion it's because we're still here
all the time it doesn't mean we need to
we're gonna take steps we're gonna work
on our skills we're gonna be in the
world but when we tune into the true
self this eternal part of us we don't
have the same
fears that are taking over life every
day you know one of my other favorite
chapters danica is the warrior chapter
right and this um sanskrit word is uh
kostria this warrior part of us um you
know in yogananda's commentary he says
something throw yourself into the din of
battle and do not worry about results so
this means when we're living from our
heart when we are taking right action
dharma so we've concentrated our energy
and then we see where we want to put it
we go for it we create we're not riddled
with fear of what if this doesn't work
out what if you know they don't like me
[Music]